cognizable is about to start his sixth
season in the nfl
and his second on the las vegas raiders
and the defensive end
that during pride month excuse me and
the defensive end that during pride
month was the right time
to come out of the closet making him the
first active nfl player to ever do so
what's up people i'm carl massif i'm at
my house here in west chester
pennsylvania
just want to take a quick moment to say
that i'm gay i've been meaning to do
this for a while now
but i finally feel comfortable enough to
get it off my chest
i really have the best life i got the
best family friends and job a guy could
ask for
i'm a pretty private person so i hope
you guys know that i'm really not doing
this for attention
um i just think that representation and
visibility are so important
um i actually hope that like one day
videos like this and the whole coming
out process are just
not necessary um but until then you know
i'm gonna do my best and do my part to
cultivate a culture that's accepting
that's compassionate
and i'm gonna start by donating 100 000
to the trevor project
they're an incredible organization
they're the number one suicide
prevention service for lgbtq youth in
america
and they're truly doing incredible
things and i'm very excited to be
a part of it help in any way that i can
and i'm really pumped to see what the
future holds
yeah so lots of reaction to this uh so
far yeah lindsey says very very proud of
him and that's exactly the feedback he's
getting so players and teams
are showing the support his team the
raiders retweeted carl's message saying
adding
proud of you carl and sort of the nfl
saying the nfl family is proud of you
nfl commissioner roger goodell released
a statement saying the nfl family is
proud of carl
for courageous truth today
representation matters we share his hope
that someday soon statements like his
will no longer be newsworthy
as we march toward full equality for the
lgbtq plus community
we wish carl the best of luck this
coming season
that carl also further wrote on
instagram right now i'm sitting in a
moment of gratitude and relief
sadly i've agonized over this moment for
the last 15
years only until recently thanks to my
family and friends especially connor
cason and francis that it seemed
possible for me to say publicly and
proudly that i'm gay
i'm also incredibly thankful for the nfl
my coaches and fellow players for their
support
i would not have been able to do this
without them from the jump i was
greeted with the utmost respect and
acceptance i stand on the shoulders of
giants incredible people
who paved the way for me to have this
opportunity
yeah yeah that's fantastic one of those
people would of course
be michael sam who was the first openly
gay player ever selected in the nfl
draft
but unfortunately never ended up playing
in a regular season game
michael tweeted last night carl thank
you for owning your truth and especially
your donation to the trevor project
lgbr lgbtq people are more likely to
commit suicide than heterosexuals
i hope and pray people will take note to
this thank you again carl and look
forward to seeing you play
on the field yeah carlos is so happy he
is donating to the trevor project
marta says the times are changing
france's amazing donation joshua says
yay for him um carlos says i'm so
supportive of this carl
i'm a long time nfl print fan proud of
him we need to keep evolving
assuming this quick moment love him way
to go what are your thoughts
yeah i i like to echo that sentiment
it's the it's that whole keep evolving
part you know there there are um
certain areas of of society
where still this is a difficult thing
for people to
to do you know based on the job that
you're
doing or the community that you're a
part of
and i've never been
heavily into sports like i'm a fan of
sports but i'm not heavily into it
but i've never seen and certainly not
when i was younger
did not see um organized sports
as a safe place for my friends that were
in the lgbtq plus community like i
didn't it didn't seem like a safe place
for them and
i think that because of that it it
turned them away from something maybe
that they might have loved to do
or found success in when they were
younger
um and it is this is
late uh to do i mean in 2021 it's late
to to
be able to say you know all the nfl to
be able to say we support
you know uh our players in this um
it would have been nice i think for that
to always have been part of the culture
there
but i will say that evolution is
important and uh
this is a this is moving in the right
direction i certainly hope
that um uh the players that are in the
league now
or are striving to be in the league um
will all feel accepted for whoever
they are yeah that's the thing i think i
mean people always say oh it's 2021 why
do we still need to hear this he's the
first one
to openly say this when he's in the nfl
like that's crazy so yeah you just know
the
homophobia that still is in organized
sports like michael sam talked about
that like after he came out he was he
was uh drafted
a camera what team used drafted for um
but he talked about like the stigma in
the locker room
like how he was treated in the locker
room there's still major homophobia so
yeah we need people to come out and say
this kind of stuff and i love
his video too like when he says it and
sometimes when you
see these if it's an interview i even
remember colton underwood a few months
ago like he when he said it when he said
the words i'm gay
you could see it almost like just barely
escape his lips
but carl just said like after he says
i'm gay carl had immediately has a
little bit of a smile on his face
like he just he's he's happy to say it
in a way like he doesn't he doesn't feel
like he's
he's being held back so yeah i hope i
mean i love all the messages that are
that are coming out about like how the
nfl is supporting him
i hope that's the truth because i mean i
mean i hope this
is a pr move for the nfl because i mean
we saw last year how they
apologized to colin kaepernick the colin
kaepernick still doesn't have
a job so we'll see how carl is tricked
off see carl is under contract
but hope it's not like in a year or so
carlos let go from the raiders
and he disappears off the radar so i
hope this isn't just you know a pr move
by that felt through shoulder support
but really it's going to come down to
behind the scenes
how he's treated the locker room how
players out in the field treat them
because you know
we've heard those stories like people
throwing slurs at people when they're on
the field like your opponent
so i hope carl is full of respect yeah
this is a huge move
i hope this opens the door to a lot more
people coming out because rowdy is the
nfl sort of tell you people the nfl has
been around for 100 years
there have been gay men in the nfl
before
they just haven't been comfortable to
come out so the fact that yeah and
people
are this is a young player so yeah it's
amazing absolutely yeah and it's it's
funny when people are shocked that they
might
that that notion could be true right
shocked that there could have been
players that they uh
uh that they were big fans of that just
were never able to come out because of
the culture because of the even because
of the fandom
like this has got to be a moment where
you can move forward and go carl was
uh you know other players will go yep i
saw carl do this and you know what i'm
i'm going to do this too and i can feel
safe
doing it and still be a kick-ass player
like let's go
right yeah exactly so hopefully yeah
this opens the floodgates in a way in
professional sports